s'agissant des stations de sports
d'hiver nous avons estimé que la
circulation épidémique mais aussi la
situation des hôpitaux dans les régions
concernées notamment en auvergne
rhône-alpes et bourgogne franche comté
ne nous permettent pas d'envisager une
ouverture pour la période de noël
je salue du reste la position de la
commission européenne visant à une
position harmonisée en europe sur le
sujet et dans le sens de la prudence
quelle que soit l'importance des efforts
que sont prêts à consentir les
gestionnaires et responsables de ces
stations il ne serait en effet pas
prudent de laisser se rassembler des
flux très importants de population avec
des activités susceptibles de solliciter
par ailleurs les services hospitaliers
mais bien entendu il sera loisible à
chacun chacune et à tous de se rendre
dans ces stations pour profiter de l'air
pur de nos belles montagnes des
commerces hors bars et restaurants qui
seront couverts simplement toutes les
remontées mécaniques et des équipements
collectifs seront fermés au public
bien entendu nous avons engagée avec les
élus des vallées concernés les
professionnels du secteur des
discussions en vue d'une part d'
indemniser les pertes de recettes
occasionnés par cette décision et
d'autre part de préparer au mieux la
période suivante à partir de janvier où
nous l'espérons grâce aux mesures que
nous prenons aujourd'hui l'amélioration
attendue de la situation sanitaire nous
permettra une ouverture plus large
nous règlerons également la situation
des saisonniers dont je n'ignore ni
drôle ni le poids dans cette activité
très importante pour notre pays